hello YouTube channel soon our fans this
is grunge in here welcome to the eighth
part of the dirtiest tricks I am
continuing my coverage of the tricky
recruit are against the classical King
pawn opening that is let's say after
Aoife Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to c4 now in the last two
lectures I have covered the Moon Knight
to f6 so those of you who haven't
watched them I have highlighted here in
the annotations in this lecture we are
going to concentrate on the move Bishop
to c5 after this
why should castle on the Kings side and
the main move over here is Knight to f6
apart from that there are other moves
but they are pretty rare and that's why
I have not included in this lecture
after mood light to f6 Black has a very
simple idea black just want to castle on
the Kings side and complete his
development but here comes the Big Shot
that is the move d4 boom this is a very
strong gambit known as Italian caught
levansky gambit which many strong
players are not aware of it
the good point from the white
perspective is it contains lots of
tricks that means you can finish up the
black very very quickly can you believe
the main move over here is Bishop
captures d4 and how many of your
opponent knows this I bet not many
because nobody just throw a bishop pair
just like that so to understand that we
need to know what is wrong with our
moves the first more I want to consider
is Knight captures d4 after this
why should capture the e5 pawn and
there's a threat on f7 looming so
accordingly black has two choices the
first obvious looking movies castle
after the castle white should continue
with the move Bishop to e3 so there are
double hits on the night and if the
knight moves then the bishop drops so
accordingly black has the only move left
that is Knight to e6 but after this
following sequence will emerge white
with a winning position here white
continue with the move Bishop captures
c6 so Bishop captures seafire is the
next threat that responses force Black
has to capture this bishop but
afterwards Bishop captures f7 gives a
check to the black King
and doesn't matter if the black captured
the bishop or move the king for example
if the King moves then the bishop
drawbacks to the b3 and now there are
two threats which black cannot bury both
of them so very obvious looking mu who
is Bishop to b6 afterwards Knight check
will nab the exchange just early in the
opening so this is a wonderful trick
exists in this line which many strong
player has fallen into
now the second move over here is defy
after the Moody file why should capture
this phone and if black foolishly
captured the D pawn then c3 will nab a
piece because if the knight moves then
the night on the d5 will drop so
accordingly at this point
black need to castle on the Kings side
afterwards once again what can play this
move Bishop to b3 and this time around
black doesn't have even Knight to e6
so that means black has to try this
while looking move that is b5 but here I
can go for this sequence that is Bishop
captures e3 Bishop captures d4 Queen
captures d4 and B captures c4 and Knight
to c3 after the whole transaction you
can easily say that not only white
emerged with a couple of pawns up but
black Queen side points has been
shattered in the next few moves
White is going to eat that C pawn so all
in all it's a winning position for white
so by this analysis we can easily say
that at this position Knight captures d4
is not good
the second move is Bishop to b6 after
Bishop to b6 white will capture the epon
and black has few choices if black takes
the ebon that is Knight captures efore
then Queen can go to the d5 square and
we have a similar trick exist which I
have shown in many videos so here what
is threatening to make black on epsilon
as well as capturing the night and
that's why black is going to lose a
piece the second move is if Knight goes
to the g4 then white has this dazzling
piece sacrifice that is Bishop captures
f7 boom number 2 very obvious black has
to accept this and after this we have
this my check which not only gain the
piece but black needs to be very careful
over here so for example in one game my
opponent foolishly played the MU King to
g8 afterwards there is a checkmate in
two it's a easy one right so just the
Queen check and after King to f8 Queen
to f7 as a checkmate
don't expect this sort of things very
often but let's say after King goes to
somewhere else for example King - eh
then right can regain the peace and the
following sequence which illustrate how
good white position is so here in one
game my opponent continuing the Moon
Knight captures Aoife and after Queen to
G 3d6 not only white emerge with her
clear upon up but black has lost the
castle ride
the third move at this point is he
captures d4
but here what can continue with the
movie fie and it looks like we are in
some sort of similar position right yes
it's a maxilla Attack Position which I
have covered in detail in the dirty
chest trick 6 so it's a great way if you
know the max length then we can force
your opponent to fall into via a
different route for those of you who
haven't seen this max Lange attack here
I have highlighted in the education so
you can watch that video and learn what
you should do after the movie fie
[Music]
so finally we come to the move Bishop
captures deform after this
why should certainly capture this bishop
and there are two moves exist over here
the main movies Knight captures d4 which
I am going to look at first after Knight
captures d4 White has two good replies
if you know that your opponent is a
aggressive player you can try some
tricky stuff while the move Bishop to g5
Bishop to g5 more or less in white black
to play the move at 6:00 and then g5 but
this is exactly white once because now
comes the third blow that is the move f4
boom number three here black has few
options but all leads to disaster so
let's see each fight on the first move
is G captures h4 after this y can
capture the epon and you can easily see
that two of the Black Knights are
hanging and the knight on f6 cannot even
move because there are some nasties
looming on the episode so what will gain
back the piece while big interest
the second movies he captures f4 after
this where I can capture this night and
when the black recaptured the piece now
white can play the move route capture
therefore and there is a nasty beam on
this diagonal that's why black cannot
move the night and white will emerge
with a clear piece
the Todd move is night captures efore
after this white can capture the upon
which not only threatened this night but
there is also a nasty looming on the f7
so to parry both the threat Black has
the only choice that is night to e6 but
after this Queen to f3 leads to the
winning position for the white last but
not least if G captures f4 then we have
this move that is rook captures f4 boom
number 4 very obvious is Black has to
accept this so he captures f4 afterwards
Queen captures d4 and black is in a very
funny position right so there is a pin
on this diagonal there is a pin on this
diagonal and that means Knight cannot
move and that means black is going to be
a piece down
so those are some of the wonderful
tricks exist if your opponent plays move
such as at six ng5 the main line start
with the more immediate fo
white wants to destroy the black center
and start attacking black on the
kingside so accordingly black has to
play the move d6 instead of d6 in one
game my opponent try the move Knight to
c6 but this move miserably failed
because of Bishop captures f7 boom
number six where your versus King has to
accept this and after this white can
capture the e pawn not only regaining
the piece but black King has been
misplaced
and in case if you are wondering hang on
what happens if Knight captures ePHI
then oh I can give this check and when
the King moves then one can capture this
piece
yes material is balance but white is in
great attacking position as well as
black King lost the castle right
so it conclude that d6 is force at this
point after the move d6 why should
capture the e pawn and when the black
will capture now once again what can
play the move Bishop to g5 so it has a
simple idea to double the black pawn and
accordingly may move players by the
black over here is Bishop to e6 so
attacking the c-4 bishop here white
should defend that bishop with the move
Knight to a3 and now there are two moves
has been tried in the first game my
opponent tried to move Queen to e7 so it
has an idea to castle on the Queen side
so I immediately put brake on the plant
why the moves c3 and after some thinking
my opponent goes for Bishop capture c4
so he's trying to do some tricky stuff
but before he can execute something I
played an intermediate move that his
Bishop captures f6 so black has to
capture with the pawn and now I grab the
bishop my abundance idea was to play the
move Queen to c5 so there are some nasty
looming but the discovere check but here
I simply kept this Knight
very obvious when the black recapture I
have this idea that is rope to see one
black doesn't have any option at left so
black has to accept the spawns so my
opponent grab the points and then I grab
the c7 point and then he grabbed the
people which allow white to enter in
endgame which is much better for the
white so you can easily see that this
rooks are not connected and both the
rooks of the white are posted on the
seventh rank so although there is a pawn
down situation for white it's a winning
position now in the game my opponent
played the move rook to b8 and after I
played the move King to f1 he played a
suicidal move that his rook to f8 which
allow me to finish him instantly I'm a
clear Rukh up at this point but instead
of this even though let's say if he
hasn't played the rook F at mu then the
following sequence will illustrate how
dangerous white attack is so here white
can exchange the rook following engine
moves can easily conclude that white has
this very position
now instead of Queen to e7 at this point
in second game my opponent tried to move
at six and that you are going to face
more often here I should continue the
move Bishop captures f6 and after G
captures f6 White has this move that is
c3 so once again dislodging the night
from the d4 square and when the knight
moves then white can play this move
Queen to f3 so that means what is
definitely going to regain the f6 pawn
but also what can gain a important tempo
while the move look to d8 so
understanding that my opponent plays
over here Queen to e7 so he just want to
castle on the Queen side if I allowed
but here I capture the pawn which has a
threat to capturing the roof so my
opponent has to forcefully accept this
Queen trade and then he played the MU
King to himself
for a moment it looks like black is fine
but after rook to f1 there are some
long-term problems for the black king
so here by distracting to capture the
bishop and playing rook to f7 so my
opponent captured the bishop and when
white we captured he defend the f7 pawn
via the move rook a to f8 once again it
doesn't look like white has a huge
advantage but just one move and you will
see how dangerous this position is for
the black the move is my to e3
boom number seven
there are so many threads over here the
first obvious threat is white can place
the knight on d4 and then at least get
the c7 or the f7 pawn the second obvious
threat is white can capture this at six
pawn and then give this knight check
which will regain the piece and the
third of your threat is Knight to g4
which once again attacked at six as well
as pressurized the e4 pawn and all in
all black cannot bury all these threats
and white will emerge with a clearly
winning endgame
so so far we have seen the wonderful
tricks exist in Knight to d4 line
instead of Knight to d4 at this point
your opponent can also try the sideline
stuff that is e captures d4
but once again there are some nasty
tricks exist in this line so you should
see them
here what should continue with the movie
fire and black has two choices if black
foolishly take this pawn then the rook
to e1 and black will lose a piece so
that is not possible
accordingly the first move bracken tries
Knight to e4 after this why should
continue with the move Queen to g4 which
has a double hit tonight as well as g7
pawn I got this position in one game and
hear my opponent responded with the move
d5 so I captured the g7 pawn and when
the rook moves then I attacked the rook
one more time with the move Bishop to e6
so that forced black to play the move
Queen to e7 but that will allow me to
capture the depot and if you carefully
look at this position white will emerge
at least with an exchange on
last but not least your opponent can
also try to counter-attack
just like the max Lang attack via the
move defy but here I can capture the
night and when black capture the bishop
white can actually capture the g7 pawn
the idea is when the rook moves white
can play the move Queen to h4 now Queen
to h5 is spinning the f7 pawn and
accordingly black has to respond with
the move Queen to f6 there is no time to
capturing the g7 point immediately so
for example if your opponent foolishly
captured the g7 pawn
then white has this move that is rook to
even chat and more or less this is a
winning position
four options exist if Knight to e7 then
Bishop to g5 is exceptionally strong
if King to f8 then Bishop to at six and
black will lose an exchange
if Bishop to e6 then I can simply lop of
this mission because f7 point is spin
and the most comical is King to d7
afterwards Queen two defies actually
checkmate rather nice right
so that is boom number seven we can say
so Queen to f6 is forced at this
position after Queen to f6 white can
harass this Queen why the move Bishop to
g5 and when black captured the pawn then
white once again can throw this check
with the move rook to even now there are
three moves has been tried in one quick
game my opponent foolishly played the
move King to f8 which allow me to gain
the Queen instantly after the move
Bishop to at 6 and the second game my
opponent try the move Bishop to e6 but
now we can simply capture this bishop
because the f7 pawn is spin and when the
King goes to the d7 White can actually
grab the second piece while the move
rook to c6
after we cross c6 I protected the
weakest spot why the move Queen to h3 so
not only protecting the g2 but giving
black a check so my opponent responded
with the move King to d6 and here I
played the move Knight to e2 so it's
very clear that white has to piste
against the rook but the main feature of
this position is black King has been
misplaced
now in the game my opponent captured his
Bishop but this leads to the instant
victory after 94
but even though let's say if that
doesn't happen if you check out this
position with the engine it will say
that it is clearly better for white last
but not least a very strong player has
played the MU King to d7 but then I
continued with the move Queen to h3
check and after King to d6 I gave Queen
to a3 check and when the King goes back
to the d7 White has this amazing move
that is at four at first sight it looks
like after the move at six white loses a
piece but white has a very cunning idea
and that is to move Queen to c5 boom
number H white has a sneaky but a very
solid threat that is Queen to defy and
checkmate
so black doesn't have any time to
capture the bishop
accordingly in the game my opponent try
to defend the mate while the move Queen
to g6 but after the Queen to defy check
so my opponent block the check with the
Queen then I knew Queen captures f7
check so the rook is threatened so my
opponent block the check with the night
and then I just capture this night with
the bishop and now there's a threat of
capturing the rope as well as capturing
the Queen so my opponent desperately go
for Queen to g6 hoping for the Queen
trade
but no I just played the move Queen to
defy check and after gain to D H there
is a checkmate in six I'm not going to
show here that's an exercise for you so
you can do it by yourself
so that's it I hope you enjoy this
wonderful journey of the tricky Italian
gambit line you should definitely try in
your own game and you will be surprised
how many of your opponent will fall very
very quickly with this I conclude my
tricky recruiter series and I like to
say thank you for watching all of them
and feel free to like and comment them I
will see you soon bye